the new law will go into effect in 2022
impacting when your child can enroll in
kindergarten leaving some parents really
worried and then reaching out to us on
social media victoria saha takes a look
at why this change was made and who
exactly it will impact kindergarten is a
vital year where students can advance
their basic skills from pre-k she knows
all of her letters her numbers she's
writing she's more than ready to attend
kindergarten mom chelsea sandusky was
worried when new legislation moved up
the september 30 cutoff date when a
child has to be five years old to enroll
in kindergarten the new cutoff day is
the first day of school which for clark
county will be august 8th in 2022. i
have lost sleep i have popped more gray
hairs i have been scrambling trying to
figure out what we're going to do
sandusky's daughter was going to turn
five august 31st which meant she would
have to wait another year for
kindergarten schools weren't giving her
any options but while i was getting
answers for parents the nevada
department of education told me for now
parents with students who turn five
between the first day of school and
september 30th will be allowed to
continue to kindergarten or wait until
2023. this new option is a huge relief
nevada department of education
implemented the new cutoff date because
there were concerns about the impact of
having younger five-year-olds in the
same classroom as older five-year-olds
therapist mandy barone says there are
benefits to the change gives kids the
time they need to adjust because it
gives parents a time to help their kids
with it the new law goes into affected
july 1st victoria saha live local now
other parents reached out to channel 8
hoping enrollment was based on the birth
year and not the month and date it is
important to note first day of schools
vary between the district charter
schools and private schools